peu savent ce que sont les coraux et d'où ils viennent.
Comment amener quelqu'un à se soucier des coraux
quand ce n'est qu'une abstraction qu'il comprend à peine.
S'il ne comprend ni leur nature, ni leur origine,
ni à quel point ils sont curieux, intéressants, beaux,
comment s'attendre à ce qu'il les protège ?
Alors changeons cela.
Qu'est-ce qu'un corail ? D'où vient-il ?
Les coraux naissent de différentes façons,
mais souvent par fraie en masse de tous les individus d'une espèce
une nuit par an.
Ils libèrent tous les œufs de l'année
dans la colonne d'eau,
empaquetés de spermatozoïdes.
Ces paquets remontent à la surface et se défont.
Et là, on espère très fort
qu'ils croisent œufs et sperme d'autres coraux.
Donc il faut beaucoup de coraux dans un récif
pour que tous les œufs trouvent un partenaire.
Quand ils sont fécondés, ils font comme tous les œufs :
ils se divisent encore et encore.
Faire ces photos au microscope chaque année
est un moment magique, un de mes préférés.
A la fin de cette division ils se transforment en larves,
de minuscules gouttes de graisse, grosses comme des grains de pavot
mais qui ont le même système sensoriel que nous,
percevant couleurs, lumière, textures, produits chimiques, pH.
Ils sentent la pression des vagues, entendent les sons.
Et ils utilisent ces talents
pour chercher au bas du récif un endroit où s'accrocher
et passer le reste de leur vie.
Imaginez donc trouver un lieu pour y passer votre vie
quand vous n'aviez que 2 jours.
Ils choisissent l'endroit qui leur paraît le meilleur,
ils construisent un squelette sous eux,
puis une bouche, des tentacules,
puis le plus difficile : les récifs coralliens.
Un polype corallien se divise
laissant sous lui un squelette de calcaire.
Il croît en direction du soleil.
Après des centaines d'années et beaucoup d'espèces,
vous avez une énorme structure calcaire
souvent visible de l'espace,
couverte par une fine couche de ces animaux travailleurs.
Ce ne sont que quelques centaines d'espèces, peut-être 1 000,
mais elles abritent des millions d'autres espèces,
et cette diversité stabilise le système.
C'est là qu'on trouve nos nouveaux médicaments,
de nouvelles sources de nourriture.
J'ai la chance de travailler sur l'île de Curaçao,
où nous avons encore des récifs comme ceci.
mais la plus grande part des Caraïbes et du monde
est bien plus comme cela.
Les scientifiques ont étudié en détail
la perte en récifs dans le monde,
ils en ont montré les causes de plus en plus certaines.
Mais dans mes recherches, le passé ne m'intéresse pas.
Avec mes collègues on s'intéresse au futur,
à ce qui pourrait être.
Et nous avons une infime raison d'être optimiste.
Car même dans certains récifs
qu'on aurait pu rayer de la carte il y a longtemps,
on voit parfois des bébés arriver, et survivre malgré tout.
On pense qu'ils ont la capacité
de s'adapter à des conditions invivables pour les adultes.
Ils peuvent peut-être s'adapter
un peu mieux à cette planète humaine.
Donc dans nos recherches à Curaçao,
on essaie de déterminer les besoins d'un bébé corail
à ce moment critique,
ce qu'il cherche,
et comment l'aider.
Voici 3 exemples de ce qu'on a fait
pour essayer de répondre à ces questions.
Avec une imprimante 3D, on a créé des enquêtes sur le choix des coraux,
avec différentes couleurs et textures,
et on a demandé aux coraux où ils préféraient s'installer.
On a vu que les coraux, en dehors de toute biologie,
préfèrent le blanc et le rose, couleurs d'un récif sain.
Ils préfèrent les crevasses, rainures et trous,
où ils ne risquent pas d'être piétinés
ou mangés par un prédateur.
On peut utiliser ce savoir
pour dire qu'il faut restaurer
ce rose et blanc, ces crevasses, et surfaces dures
dans nos projets de conservation.
On peut utiliser ce savoir
si on veut construire sous l'eau une digue ou une jetée.
On peut choisir des matériaux, des couleurs et des textures
qui pourraient être favorables aux coraux.
En plus des surfaces,
on étudie les signaux chimiques et microbiens
qui attirent les coraux vers les récifs.
Il y a 6 ans j'ai commencé à cultiver des bactéries
prises où des coraux s'étaient installés.
Je les ai testées une par une,
cherchant celle qui convaincrait les coraux de s'installer.
On a maintenant des souches bactériennes congelées
pouvant permettre à des coraux
d'accomplir ce processus d'installation et de fixation.
Donc en ce moment,
mes collègues sont en train de tester ces bactéries
pour voir si elles vont permettre d'obtenir plus de colonisateurs,
et s'ils survivront mieux
quand on les remettra à l'eau.
De plus on essaie de percer les mystères
d'espèces peu étudiées.
Voici un de mes coraux préférés, depuis toujours :
cylindrus dendrogyra, les cierges de la mer.
J'aime leurs drôles de formes,
leurs tentacules grassouillets et duveteux,
et parce qu'ils sont rares.
En trouver est une chance.
En fait c'est si rare
que depuis l'an dernier, ils sont espèce menacée
dans la liste des espèces en danger,
en partie parce que en plus de 30 ans de relevés,
les scientifiques n'ont jamais vu de bébé de ce corail.
On n'était même pas sûr qu'ils puissent
encore se reproduire.
Donc il y a 4 ans, on s'est mis à les suivre la nuit
pour essayer de voir quand ils frayent à Curaçao.
On a eu de bons conseils de nos collègues de Floride,
qui en avaient vu en 2007 et 2008,
et on a pu déterminer quand le frai a lieu chez nous
et y assister.
Voici une femelle à gauche, qui porte des œufs,
prête à les libérer dans l'eau.
Voici un mâle à droite, lâchant du sperme.
On a tout récupéré, fait la fécondation au labo
et on a eu des bébés nageurs de cierges de la mer au labo.
Grâce au travail de nos prédécesseurs,
et à nos 10 ans de pratique
dans l'élevage d'autres coraux,
on a obtenu que des larves aillent au bout du processus,
s'installent, se fixent
et deviennent des coraux.
Voici donc le premier bébé cierge de mer jamais vu.
(Applaudissements)
Si, pour vous, les bébés pandas sont mignons, pour moi,
ça, c'est plus mignon.
(Rires)
Donc on commence à comprendre les secrets
de la reproduction des coraux et comment les aider.
C'est vrai pour le monde entier :
on trouve de nouvelles façons de manipuler les embryons
pour qu'ils s'installent
et peut-être même des méthodes pour les conserver à basse température
et ainsi pouvoir préserver leur diversité génétique
et travailler avec eux plus souvent.
Mais c'est très rudimentaire.
On est limité en espace, en personnel,
en nombre de cafés qu'on peut boire à l'heure.
Comparez à d'autres crises,
d'autres préoccupations de la société.
On a des technologies de pointe dans le médical, la défense,
la science,
et même l'art.
Mais pour l'écologie, on est en retard.
Pensez au travail le plus difficile que vous ayez fait.
Beaucoup diraient « être parent ».
Ma mère a dit qu'être parent
rendait la vie bien plus étonnante et bien plus difficile
qu'on aurait pu l'imaginer.
J'essaie d'aider les coraux à devenir parents depuis plus de 10 ans.
Observer les merveilles du vivant
m'a certainement remplie d'étonnement au plus profond de mon âme.
Mais j'ai vu comme il leur est difficile de devenir parents.
Les cierges ont encore frayé il y a 15 jours,
on a récupéré leurs œufs pour le labo.
Là vous voyez un embryon se diviser
à côté de 14 œufs non fécondés
qui éclateront.
Infectés par des bactéries, ils exploseront,
et ces bactéries menaceront la vie de cet unique embryon
qui a une chance de vivre.
On ne sait pas si c'est une erreur de manipulation,
on ne sait pas
si le corail de ce récif-là souffre toujours d'une faible fertilité.
Quelle que soit la cause,
on a beaucoup de travail avant d'obtenir que des bébés coraux
grandissent, se fixent, ou peut-être, sauvent les récifs.
Alors peu importe qu'ils vaillent des centaines de millions,
les récifs, à la fois animaux, végétaux, microbes, champignons, travaillent dur.
Ils produisent de l'art, de la nourriture des médicaments.
On a presque anéanti toute une génération de coraux.
Mais quelques-uns ont survécu malgré toutes nos actions,
et maintenant il est temps de les remercier pour leur travail
et de leur donner toutes leurs chances pour élever les récifs du futur :
leurs bébés coraux.
Merci beaucoup !
(Applaudissements)